previously on the walking dead if i do
say something
ah [ __ ] drive
sure he was gonna okay shoot his brain
down
make me do this don't make me do it i
don't give a [ __ ]
look like lindsay lopez lisa lohan sorry
there's something going on
baby if you can hear this call the
police
sorry i'm not your dada hello
you need to be quiet okay
[Music]
[Applause]
i was going rest my name is
welcome back to some more walking dead
we're going to start up right away oh my
god
she's so ugly hey
back off [ __ ]
he's really good at slipping [ __ ] i hate
this part
there we go now get up get up hey don't
touch me bro
[ __ ] snooki get out of my face sketch
you got a hammer i see this this time i
can't believe i didn't see it last night
back up back up
god damn it you're desperate snooki
there we go come on
all right thank you thank you thank you
thank you
let me fix your face stop i'm attacked
more beautiful more beautiful more
beautiful
yeah she's prettier now actually
most celebrities hi there
hey there that's a nice introduction
way to make an intro nope she's just
sleeping
i don't know i think i think so
every time we remember come back oh [ __ ]
you killed one
no but they get shot a lot you've been
all by yourself through this oh yeah i
want my parents to come home now
oh they're not coming i think that might
be a little while
you know oh look i don't know what
happened
but sure what happened you put a hammer
in
to her should we do now
rape and damn sorry uh we should
we can find help before it gets dark
yeah it's not safe at night
uh the safety of daylight what
okay stay close i'll forget that's gotta
get okay
i think i'll keep it
all right we'll go during the day that's
probably not the best ideas
what what's the matter clementine you go
girl work it
on the thinking better moving faster
fingers stronger
sorry all the matter however up the
power over there
let's go down the controls are really
difficult sometimes but hey what can you
do
let's follow hey um
okay well what are they doing oh man
i ain't never getting home to mama at
this rate
that sucks hot dish night
it's missing the hot dish all right
let's click on this
what's that fellas what's the matter
should i stand
again what nah i don't want to sleep in
the tree house tonight but
i don't know if i should leave what if
my parents come home
they're not coming girl they're dead
they're zombies
i will leave i won't leave you alone
let's go somewhere
that's close okay that's a good idea
but what's wrong with the house it can't
be that different no
well there was zambia hey man holy [ __ ]
hey stop
don't eat us i'm a zombie i'm not gonna
don't eat us
i'm just gonna hate you for a second you
and the little one we're both gonna give
us the chomp
the chomp do you know what's going on
hell this is
no idea so you've seen them then
they're so sexy you could say that i'm
sean
sean what's up sean
me and clementine i'm chat back up for
mac
i don't trust you chat we shouldn't be
out in the open like this how about you
help us clear the way and we'll take you
and your daughter out of here
and down to my family's farm it should
be safer there
i'm not a dad well he is asian so i
trust him um
i'm just some guy just some guy some guy
yeah she's alone let's get going
staying put for too long is a mistake
don't worry about it she's with me
what do you want all right i want that
cap
what do you want to do monster's coming
then mom's just counting
we gotta go quick let's go
oh snap oh no i gotta click it
come on late
how can he someone fix his leg or
something
goalie pop that card go ahead and die
and he's like [ __ ]
that you guys too slow uh
oh no
go go go go go go oh he's screwed
ah nah seems like you saved a bunch of
lives today
uh they wanted me she's like but we want
to dance
all right nailed it
oh look at that beautiful
i don't know what's with the graphics in
this game i can't tell if i like it or
not
i don't know it's so weird
we're going home typical american car
just saying all right
oh creepy house but it's
i don't know what i feel about it i'm
gonna run over hey
my mama's gonna be in a snit no sweat
man i'll catch you tomorrow night
dammit how did hell does he talk it was
nice to meet you both
it was a good time running away from
them zombies
good time chet good time i like how
she's so close with him even though
they're just met
i was worried it'd be bad here too and
quiet as usual let's make sure
i thought but that ain't nothing new
i wouldn't have made it back without yet
well i'm glad you took him with you then
glad chet made it you've brought a
couple guests
uh-huh uh
we just need a little we just need help
it won't stay long
good you're welcome to stay here but
just for the night i don't run a bed and
breakfast
well you don't look like a very good one
anyway oh
no she's not technically might not just
some guy who found her alone
honey do you know who this is i'm taking
responsibility
yes well i just said that i didn't know
her
looks like you hurt your leg pretty bad
there yeah
but it fixed itself when i pushed the
car it's not doing so good
i can help you out sean i'm gonna check
on your sister
you take a seat up on the porch and i'll
go see what i have
all right because going inside is way
too safe i'll just sit out here
and why look after the kid when you can
take care of me yeah
this is swollen to hell just like my
penis
who said that it could be worse it could
be worse that's what it sounds like
seems like things got awful bad in the
cities what did you say your name was
i yeah i didn't well
now's the time i should remember that
doesn't matter well if you're gonna be
here overnight i'm gonna need it
ah come on fine
my name is lee [ __ ] well lee
just leave i'll take it i'm herself no
it's it's only lee not lee
what how'd this happen
i don't remember i think jumping
i don't remember running from something
just like everybody else
he doubts me what the [ __ ] is the girl
scene
uh she's safe she's safe now you're
serious about taking care of her then
what choice is there of course i'll take
care
we got another displaced family of three
sleeping in the barn
you and your daughter are welcome to
rest there thank you
i didn't get your name darling
clementine can't imagine what you've
been through clementine
poor little girl looking after her until
we uh find her parents
hey dad so i'm thinking first thing
tomorrow
we got to reinforce the fence around the
farm
first thing tomorrow it looks really
awkward what they're doing from his
angle but there's some serious
[ __ ] hitting the fan i don't think
anyone that's right i'm sweating
in front of the lady your son's right
he's running
fortify this place stuff like that
doesn't happen around here sean
dad i'm sorry lee tell him what you saw
out there man you didn't even see the
zombies
dead people walking dead people well do
what you think you should
we got plenty of chores as it is lean
those folks in the barn can help out in
the morning
we got to do it really i already really
do i mean really we got we're all right
i'm all done here
it should start to feel better tomorrow
thanks all right
finally hot or the swelling doesn't go
down you're probably dealing with an
infection
where we come from
all right
i think this episode will be a lot of
not that much action
more like uh character development
i mean we learned the character and
sorry
uh all right you know it smells like
duty
totally duty never had anyone called
[ __ ] my mom
and dad ah don't worry girl
how far is savannah pretty i don't know
oh 485 i knew that
she sleeps with a hat on come on
oh oh the zombies are planning something
this is a nightmare don't worry
there's something with his wife but we
don't know what
hey get up hey nice mustache bruh
i'm itchy well you slept in a barn
little lady
lucky you don't have spiders in your
hair but yeah
your daddy's steering them all the way
yeah i'm not in here daddy this is
awkward baby
i'm kenny what's up me there's a tractor
kill him we better get going or we won't
hear the end of it
that's my boy ken jr we call him duck
though
i can't imagine why because
quack of course see
it's like like a little kid from happy
wheels you were on your way to making
my family's feet well megan is on the
way and
personally i'd appreciate the company of
a guy who can knock a couple of heads
together if he has to
what does the hell does that mean i'll
sleep with the girl that's the girl ah
gotta consult the missus i understand
honey
duck this is lee and uh what's the
girl's name
clementine that is a very pretty name
that is a pretty name well we should get
to work we've all seen what those things
can do out there so the faster we get
this fence up
the better let's do it yeah
you can't do [ __ ] you can sit on the
tractor and yell at me whenever i take
away
exactly that's all you can do cool
that's not cool at all you seriously
what's wrong with that i can keep an eye
on your little girl here on the porch
we can i don't like i don't want to
leave her with you but i guess i don't
have to
all right let me see
play a little more all right lady
look at my leg it's all fixed sorry
you have such pretty hair it gets lost
thank you
oh god damn it all right
hey there what's up man kitty what's up
kenny
need anything you need any help mayor no
i don't know anything about cars but
mm-hmm
do you need any help what do you mean
i mean little girl you know what you're
doing you got kids your own
no i don't no kids no kids with a liked
one then
you know i know you know you know how it
is
i don't know so what's your what's your
plan here
get back on down to lauderdale and let
this mess get sorted out
yeah handing out shots national guard
will do its thing
on the odd chance things got too bad we
could
hop on my boat i guess you've got it i'm
gonna guess
i'm a commercial i'm gonna take a boat
ride catching mackerel dolphin
whatever's biting i love macra dolphins
about it but the boat's not that bad
yeah you can't eat dolphins
i don't really give a [ __ ] about his son
but i guess i gotta ask about it good i
think
katy's got a sister up in memphis we
were coming back from visiting her
we were in a gas station and some guy
grabbed my boy
i thought he was kidnapping him i was on
the [ __ ] in about two seconds and
god damn what a shame just lucky i was
there
we saw a lot of bodies before we
stumbled upon herschels
we're a tough family lee ain't nothing
gonna faze us
see you very inspirational see you later
dude
good talk man good time see how
clementine is doing
hey there girl what's up girl
so um you turn the creator and chill
i think we're doing just fine clementine
was just telling me about first grade
oh how was that it's easy
well yeah that was a nice conversation
right there
anyway it's almost like we didn't see
people eating each other for the past
three days
it's peaceful here you know her face
scares me
a lot i'm not gonna lie so what what are
you doing corporate besides
freaking people out without faith i'm a
veterinarian back in fort lauderdale
yeah like herschel here except
more with dogs and cats and uh not
horses
what is it that you i used to talk about
university of georgia we have to hope
that we can go back to our job
soon back to normal it can't stay like
this
well my mistake my mistake
we'll all be home we know that she's a
kenny just drove we passed so many
people that needed help and
we just passed people over some
just just it's okay it's fine
you don't have to say anymore for a
little thing i want to go home tomorrow
but even then i can't take away the
things we
the things doc went through come on
don't dwell over the past
you gotta look forward back to them
you know not what we saw
you just never realized when something
is happening to you
what you're being given maybe this will
all work out
you're up to maybe you gotta be yeah
exactly i knew
these past couple days at least back in
a bit okay lee
all right i think with those
inspirational little words
we'll spin a couple of circles and then
we'll end this episode
but like a period if you enjoyed i know
this episode was not that eventful
uh from what i've heard episode 2 is
going to be
the most uh where they all the action is
and the good when the story actually
gets good so
i guess we'll learn the character and
get into it and eventually
we'll have some awesome let's play so
i guess that's it